there are many things that humans do
that have nothing to do with
contributing to the survival of the
individual at least nothing obvious to
do with it so when we do mathematics and
when we do poetry and when we do ballet
dancing and all the things that make
life worth living it's very hard to make
the case that this contributes to
individual survival it clearly doesn't
what you can make a case for is that the
possession of the kind of brain that's
capable of doing those things
contributed to individual survival in
our ancestral past so it's not the
mathematics itself it's not that
actually doing algebra helps anybody to
survive but having the kind of big brain
that incidentally proves itself capable
of doing algebra having that kind of big
brain probably did improve our survival
weather because it literally made us
better
I don't know catching prey or finding
nuts or something of that sort or
weather weather in accordance with the
sexual selection theory you just
mentioned it's attractive to the
opposite sex
this is a theory of a man called Jeffrey
Miller who is a very interesting
evolutionary psychologist and he we do
have a bit of a puzzle as to why the
human brain did get so big really rather
suddenly it's actually one of the more
rapid pieces of evolution that we know
over the last 3 million years or so the
human brain has swelled up enormously
and there are various theories for why
this should be
jeffrey miller's theory is that as you
say the mind is a kind of human peacocks
tail and being clever is sexiest is what
there would be one way to put it but it
would manifest itself in the ability to
I don't know
remember epic poetry or something of
that sort I'm there all sorts of
different ways in which in particular
cultures it might manifest itself